[Music]
at google data centers we have a
relentless focus on performance
our data centers are more than just
buildings with a collection of machines
wired together
they house clusters of hundreds of
thousands of servers
in locations across the globe that need
to act as a unified network
so what does it take to operate and
build them efficiently at massive scale
it all comes down to four core
principles performance
availability security and sustainability
to optimize for performance we don't
rely on off-the-shelf components
we customize the design and build of
almost every part of the stack
for ultra high performance this includes
electrical substations
servers racks and even how we operate
cooling plants
you might think that means we're using
high-end computers but
at google we build from the bottom up
commodity hardware
underpins our custom tech stack that
runs hundreds of thousands of jobs
across these machines
to give you distributed performance and
scale but
this doesn't mean we're using the
desktop computer you're used to at home
although your computer has a lot of
technology that's optimized for how you
use it
our data center servers use only the
components needed for lean
high performance when multiplied by the
thousands we provide
you a sweet spot between performance and
cost
google cloud servers are built using the
google titan chip
from the time of manufacturing titan
helps secure every server through its
entire lifecycle
it uses root of trust technology which
cryptographically ensures that the chip
hasn't been tampered with and
significantly reduces the chance of
vulnerabilities
but what happens if a machine fails
billions of users depend on our services
being up and running 24 7.
so google uses a fault tolerant design
that's maintainable from concept
to operations at the infrastructure
level
this boils down to constant monitoring
of every hardware component
electrical and mechanical system for
configuration
activity environmental and error data
we use machine learning and machine
failure diagnostic tools
to suggest corrective actions and
because we're constantly upgrading
and reconfiguring our infrastructure our
hardware operations teams
do deployments maintenance upgrades and
repairs of all hardware
24 7. this all comes with the key
responsibility of protecting
and securing our data centers for every
user
and google cloud customer more on that
next time on
discovering data centers
you